i was completely blown away by fleabag
and
i remember i got sent the first episode
and i seen phoebe's name and i was like
right whatever this is going to be is
going to be
gold dust surely so but without further
ado
um and with the magic of the internet if
i say these names they're going to pop
up on screen
and you'll be able to see our wonderful
nominees so please first
join us in welcoming suran jones saran
you can struggle with your camera and
you hold there you go
perfect thankful you did it so good to
you sir and thank you so much for
joining us
obviously suran is nominated for anne
lister
her performance in gentleman jack um
a kind of historical romp through the
life of the landowner and
in dust and lister who of course had
whole
other side in that she had a very big
plan to take a wife
um and all of that was well documented
in a series of coded
diaries more of which we will hear about
shortly welcome sir and thank you so
much for joining us
next let's see if we can get to see
glenda jackson the
legendary glenda jackson um who is
nominated
for her performance as maud in the
incredible um
one-off drama elizabeth is missing
um hopefully we'll be able to see glenda
in a moment um
maude is an elderly woman who lives with
dementia
and while she is struggling with that
she pieces together
um a double mystery now i can't quite
see glenda yet
um but i know she's here uh so i'll
let you get to grips with the camera in
a second and i'll introduce
our third um uh
nominee and i hope she won't mind if i
introduce her as being the reigning
champion
of this category uh the title holder
she's of course jody coma
um jody if we can see you hopefully
coming
oh hello jody and of course jody is
is on screen now and is in this in this
uh category for her performances
villanelle
in killing eve um she uh of course
villanelle is the the hero the heroine
of the black comedy spy thriller
uh killing eve she plays a psychopathic
assassin
um who's in a kind of cat and mouse
chase with um
an intelligence officer and of course
uh jody won the um award for her
performance in season one of killing eve
last year and she is now up for season
two
even though all of this audience will be
well ahead of everything and we're all
on season
three glenda how wonderful to see you
thank you so much for joining
thank you members helping out with all
of you
oh it's great to see you all um and we
are hoping to be joined at some point by
samantha morton
um who of course is um nominated for her
incredible role
as kirsty in i am kirsty um
and uh it looks like we're having some
technical issues so we're going to have
to wait and hopefully she will pop up on
screen at some point
in the near future but meanwhile we have
an enormous amount
to get through um all four of the uh
performances and particularly the three
that you're looking at right now the
the people playing now incredibly
powerful performances and playing
incredibly powerful women on screen um
some of these performances looked like
they might have been quite fun to play
and some of them look like they might
have been really challenging so let's
find out if that was the case um we're
going to start in a really obvious place
which is kind of what attracted you in
the first place to these particular
roles these particular characters
and even more obviously i'm going to
have to start with glenda
because you have been off our tv screen
is it 27 years as a performer um
why was this the role to bring you back
why did you want to come back and be
moored
because it deals with something that all
western
democratic societies are facing even
with the covid
epidemic and that is we are as a people
living longer
and diseases which i mean i go back a
long way
but certainly in my childhood and nobody
i knew had suffered from
alzheimer's or dementia but they are the
big ones now
and so as a society we have to
look this in the eye and in this strange
kind of way
i think i
i tremble to say there's anything
positive about covet but what i think
there is positive
is that the need for us as a nation to
take on board the necessity for social
care
because it is just out there waiting for
us like a great big black hole if we
don't do something about it
and one of the good things that has
happened lately
is this is an issue that is going up the
political ladder
and one of the things that i found most
touching
when the film came out it's based on an
extremely good book
the young woman who wrote it it is
essentially her experience with her
grandmother
where the number of people came up and
said that a member of their family had
suffered from one of these two terrible
diseases
and that i found intensely moving
actually because
you know usually you don't get that i
mean but
for this story which is of national
importance well it's more than national
but certainly is of national importance
it was a privilege really to have a part
in it
did you had you previously just sort of
turned down
you told everyone you weren't doing
television and this was one of the first
projects that came about or was this
have you been attracted all along and
then this was the one that grabbed you
i know i was out of the business for
more than 20 years but i'll never forget
those years when i couldn't find a job
even if i'd crawled on my hands and
knees to get one
so somebody sends you a script and you
like the scripture an idiot if you say
no
but i had read the book and it did make
a major impression on me but also
when i was privileged to be a member of
parliament i would
when i would occasionally go to old
people's homes or things of that nature
see people who are suffering from these
terrible diseases
and the agony of their families in many
instances when
you know their mother father didn't
recognize them anymore and those
that really makes a profound impression
on you so i was
yeah i was very excited to do it okay
um saran your character anne is based on
a real person
did you know about her before you took
this on
so i've known sally um wayne wright for
a long time we've worked together um
quite a lot and i remembered her telling
me about
this amazing place shipton hall that she
knew when
she was growing up and this amazing
woman and lister and that she'd written
a script
and she'd been she'd write so she's been
writing versions of this script for 20
years nearly
and um trying to get it um
across in the way that she wanted to but
i think before it was made with me
now it felt like a niche program
and it felt like people wanted to push
it to one side and
um that people wouldn't be interested in
a
a lesbian landowner um who dressed the
way the undressed
and um and that was the story you know
they wanted something else as the story
so so i knew about her from sally but i
i
um my very first agency was in halifax
so i kind of knew about shifting hall as
well but it wasn't until
my agent said look sally's written these
scripts and
it's about analysta and um i'd seen the
maxine peak one
um before ours and thought it was
brilliant and
thought the woman was brilliant but when
i read sally's scripts i was like ah
this is like um it had such a modern
feel to it
and it was the way that sally writes
in that uh you know it's a sally
wainwright script
but yet it was all based on the diaries
and then when i started to read the
diaries
how she merged her work with the actual
um entries
and letters was mind-blowing um
so i immediately wanted to do it and
yeah and i auditioned a couple of times
for it and
and got it thank goodness um
jody you've been back several times to
to play villanelle what was it that
pulled you in in the very first instance
and and
you know what is it now that makes you
keep going back to her
well in the first instance it was um
phoebe it was i think this was maybe a
year after fleabag had initially
um been on screen um and i was
completely blown away by fleabag
and i remember i got sent the first
episode and i seen phoebe's name and i
was like
right whatever this is gonna be is gonna
be gold dust surely um
and yeah i just remember reading the
first script and it feeling very fresh
and nothing like i'd really ever read
before so
initially that was it was one of them if
i don't get this i can't watch it
usually i'm quite good at letting things
go but i was like no i'm not going to be
able to let this one go
um and obviously now is a continuation
of that it's
we never anticipated the first season
being as big as it was
um and the fan base are
hugely passionate and they spread the
word and
this show became much bigger than we we
ever thought so now it's about
kind of carrying on that legacy and
trying to um keep it going and
be fresh and interesting and just do
these characters
um just this really
[Music]
you